hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde wir denke ich alle wisst bin ich
sehr gerne draußen unterwegs nicht nur
zu Fuß sondern auch mal mit dem Fahrrad
oder mit dem E-Scooter oder mit dem Auto
oder mit dem Zug oder mit dem Flugzeug
es gibt mittlerweile unfassbar viele
Fortbewegungsmittel heute soll es
allerdings nicht um Fortbewegungsmittel
gehen sondern um Straßenschilder
jedes Fortbewegungsmittel benötigt
Straßenschilder außer vielleicht
Flugzeuge das ist im Himmel ein bisschen
unnötig dann ich habe mich auf jeden
Fall mal wieder in die Weiten des
Internets hinaus begeben und nach den
interessantesten unglaublichsten
verrücktesten und vor allem auch
witzigsten Straßenschilder angeschaut
wow fangen wir direkt an mit diesem hier
muss man aufpassen dass Aliens nicht
irgendwie vielleicht eine Kuh auf die
Straße senden
ist einfach Amerika ne und das hier ist
tatsächlich auch in Amerika denn hier
ist jemand mit seinem Fahrrad was auch
irgendwie nur einen Rat hat in
irgendeinen Loch gefallen und wird dann
von dem Krokodil aufgefressen Bro da ist
weit und breit nicht mal Wasser zu sehen
ich frag mich in Amerika wirklich gar
nichts mehr wo wir allerdings gerade
schon in diesem wunderschönen Land da
hinten über den Teich rüber niemanden in
den Atlantik Teich
wo wir allerdings gerade schon bei
Amerika sind erklärt mir mal bitte das
hier
da sind fliegende Rentiere irgendwie auf
den Straßen da muss man auch nicht
aufpassen wenn die einfach drüber
fliegen können wir hatten ja allerdings
vorhin eine Situation wo ein
Fahrradfahrer mit nur einem Rad hinten
irgendwie über Löcher in der Straße
hingefallen ist und dann wurde er von
dem Krokodil aufgefressen sowas
ähnliches gibt's doch in einem anderen
Ort in Amerika und zwar hier aber ohne
Krokodil und irgendwie in grün was halt
irgendwie impliziert dass man das machen
soll
das ergibt wenig Sinn und mindestens
genauso wenig Sinn ergeben diese beiden
Straßenschilder da sind nämlich
irgendwie so Figuren die klettern da
hoch und klettern vom einen
Straßenschild rüber in das andere ich
weiß nicht ob das Photoshop ist oder ob
die da wirklich so stehen aber es ist
Amerika von daher
kann ich den alles zutrauen ich glaube
ich bin der größte amerikanälter der
Welt machen wir jedoch direkt weiter mit
dem nächsten kuriosen Straßenschild und
das ist meine Tastatur
wenn man diese Straßenschild sieht muss
man sich anscheinend in Acht nehmen vor
irgendwelchen stand Leuten die da
irgendwie freihändig beim Motorrad
irgendwie dicker
Amerika bleiben weil doch direkt in
diesem wunderschönen Land meine lieben
Freunde hier muss man nämlich aufpassen
dass innerhalb der nächsten 0,2 bis 3 km
irgendwelche Elche über die Straße
laufen Bruder als wenn ich jetzt sagen
ja nur in diesem 2,8 km Abstand laufen
wir da lang wenn echt dann davor da lang
läuft dann ist das Alter das ist dann
stell doch einfach nur ein Schild auf
ihn ach das darf ich dieses Land ne und
das die da hinten dann auch alle immer
denken sie seien die schlausten die
denken wirklich sind die klügste und
beste Nation der Welt
das verstehe ich einfach nicht also auf
diesem Schild steht halt einfach
Scribbles have right of way das heißt
Eichhörnchen am Vorfahrt
das hier ist ein ganz normales
Wegweisung Straßenschild aber unten
steht einfach drauf secret nuklear
Bunker entspannt
vor allem dass dieser secret übelst
geheime nuklearische Bunker einfach auch
auf dem Straßenschild vermerkt wurde
sein not in use Amerika
dann macht's doch einfach weg oder auch
beim nächsten Straßenschild ne da merkt
also das ich weiß hier passt auf vor
wilden Tieren und Kindern
brudi
hey passt lieber mal vor euch selbst auf
da hinten hier dürfen anscheinend nur
Hexen parken
keine Ahnung und hier muss man aufpassen
dass sich plötzlich Sonnen Dinosaurier
raptorix mit Kalle Italy Poster über die
Straße läuft ja okay das könnte halt
wirklich ein Joke sein und so aber viele
Dinge die man hier halt auch siezen
einfach nur so schwachsinnig
Bro hey ich frag mich wirklich nichts
mehr oder echt schon weh diese dumm
heißt
eure eigene Sprache nicht mal und da
steht hier verstehe ich nicht mal
ey die Stellen Schilder da hinten auf
die einfach das ergibt ja gar keinen
Sinn ich meine das einzige ich zeig's
euch ja noch mal das einzige was ich da
wirklich erkennen kann ist ein Typ der
auf dem Dach steht und vielleicht wegen
Nässe Glatze oder Schnee halt irgendwie
runterfällt aber dann macht halt auch
dieses verbinden keinen Sinn weil was
soll das dann heißen so hey wenn Du
gerade dabei bist vom Dach zu fallen
pass auf mach's besser nicht ja danke
hatte ich jetzt auch nicht vor Zombies
ahead chillig
chillig
ich
seh grad hier das nächste ich verstehe
es einfach nicht ne ich meine was ist
das
muss man jetzt aufpassen dass ein Auto
vom Himmel fällt oder muss man selber
aufpassen dass man irgendwo runterstürzt
aber dann ist er ist ja das Digger ey
komm scheiß drauf hier beim nächsten auf
hey es gibt keinen Sinn mehr hier sind
zweimal one way-schild aber einmal nach
rechts und einmal nach links in der
gleichen Straße das heißt es ist dann
quasi nicht nicht in die eine Richtung
und wenn die anderen sondern in beide
Richtungen also es ist eine ganz normale
Strafe
boah ey stimmt nicht meine mein Code und
schmeißt ihn darüber
wisst ihr was
ich habe noch locker 25 weitere
Straßenschilder
aber ich lasse es sein komm ich zeige
euch noch das was ich hier gerade
gesehen habe und dann mache ich
vielleicht irgendwann zweites Video wenn
es euch gefallen hat aber für heute bin
ich raus mit der Dummheit ich bin so ein
Mensch ich könnte sterben daran wenn
andere Leute zu blöd sind ich zeige es
einmal hier
keebright unten Pfeil nach links hey no
job nee nicht mit mir macht eure Regeln
in diesem Land denkt ihr seid die besten
okay aber lasst mich in Ruhe damit okay
danke schön